well welcome back i'm delighted to say
i'm joined by somebody who knew the king
of rock and roll elvis presley like a
few other people in the world priscilla
presley married elvis in 1967 and were
married for six years she remained a
constant in his life despite all the
controversies she remained loyal to him
to the end priscilla joins me now live
from los angeles welcome to you
priscilla
thank you thank you pierce priscilla i
was just imagining that the movie is
just exhilarating and fantastic i want
to play clip first and then come to you
i'm going before the show
and nobody's gonna remember
[Music]
i need to get back to who i really am
[Music]
and how are you awesome
[Music]
i just got to be making the most of this
thing i can't
this could be over the flesh
[Applause]
presenter i found it unbelievably
exciting to watch this and i never knew
elvis presley you were married to elvis
presley what was it like for you to
watch this movie not least because as a
character of course playing you
oh well um
to be honest with you i was very nervous
about it because it's baslerman
and as we all know baz you know has his
own unique style which is good
but i just didn't know how he was going
to portray elvis and i was concerned
very concerned
wanted myself and jerry schilling who
used to work for elvis to go to new york
at the gala mets gala
and also to go to cannes film festival
and i hadn't seen the film yet so i
bowed out gracefully and said there's no
way i can see it because obviously i
don't know anything about what you're
doing so he arranged a
a screening for jerry and i at warner
brothers
and we didn't speak for i guess
three-fourths of the movie and i bend
over
and said to jerry well it looks like
we're going to can
it was good
it was good i have to say i i was i was
completely engrossed in it as as well as
jerry
um
boston austin austin butler did an
amazing job it was i mean he had elvis
down to a t
literally
he um
studied him for two years
you see that's fascinating because i i
just assumed he had him down to a t
uh you would know better than the most
because elvis is such a unique performer
people have tried to emulate him over
the years i think with varying degrees
of success do you think austin butler
has got him better than anyone that's
ever tried
hands down
better than anyone anyone
my daughter was quite emotional when she
saw it as i
and went my god i i mean he'd have
he just it was like watching elvis his
movements his smirk his walk his
attitude his temper
i mean it was it was like reincarnation
i mean it was it was beautifully done
beautifully and olivia deyoung plays you
were you happy with that portrayal
yes i was i mean i never we never talked
baz did all the talking of course
um but
i i thought she did a a very nice job
she was sensitive to him which i was
always to him and his needs and
what he was you know trying to do with
his life and
what he wanted out of his life
so i thought she did a very nice job
elvis was without a doubt one of the
most brilliant talents that the world of
entertainment has ever seen that's
unarguable he was also quite a
controversial figure in many ways do you
think you would have survived
this weird cancel culture that we now
have to endure
wow that's a good question i think of
that often you know what would elvis
think what would he wouldn't believe
what is going on right now to this
country or
to all over what's happening to
this planet um
he was very concerned about our
presidents uh who was ruling the country
uh
he um and people would never believe
that but he was an avid reader as well
and not just um
you know
religious books but also he was reading
what was going on in the u.s
what would he have made you think of
what is currently going on in the u.s
i'm sorry what would he have made you
think of what is currently going on in
america
oh no he wouldn't believe it i mean he
truly
you know i don't believe it i don't
think any of us believe what's going on
right now we've never been through
anything like this and it's pretty much
global but us as a country
it's baffling it's truly baffling i'm
for the first time worried about my
future for not only my children my
grandchildren as well
very unpredictable and elvis would
probably go to the president
like you did with nixon yeah put his
foot down and say what's going on
what is it that you find particularly
saddening or worrying
oh my gosh the state that we're in
i mean
my gosh i don't know what happened to
freedom
i don't know if there is freedom here
anymore
you know no one says what side they're
on
republican or
whatever you want to be um
being very careful what you say how you
say it
uh
i think we're in a very dangerous time
we're at a strange stage priscilla where
even high-profile women are scared to
say what they think a woman is
that's true
that's true how sad is that
and i mean uh it's uh
to watch this going on being very young
in the limelight and
knowing a lot of people who are in the
limelight
their fears
on what's going on not not that they're
just in the limelight but i think it's
it's spread quite a bit uh in this
country about where we're headed uh and
i often think like you asked
you know what elvis would think you know
what would he do
he he just he wouldn't he wouldn't
believe it he was a die-hard american
he was america yeah
he he loved this country he loved it
but it seems to me it seems to me
priscilla there is a there's a kind of
movement not just in america but i'll
talk about america about this there's a
movement to try and trash everything
that's come before
and that's why i was curious whether you
felt elvis whether there would be a
campaign to try and cancel him for you
know inappropriate statements
inappropriate behavior whatever it may
be inappropriate lyrics we've seen it
time and again now with so many people
that's why i was curious what you felt
because it seemed to me
he would fly in the face of so much of
what this weird culture represents
well per the movie if you saw and you
did see the movie you know a long time
it was um stated that elvis you know
uh was um a racist
he was not a racist he's never been a
racist elvis had friends black friends
friends from all over
um he loved their music he loved their
style
he loved being around you know black
musicians i mean that's domino when he
was in vegas he was in the lounge
playing and he would always we would
always go and hang out with him sammy
davis jr the same thing but always come
into the dressing room and he
loved loved being around blacks and
being around anyone actually he was just
not prejudiced in any way
so and not racist in any way so i don't
know you know this is a very frightening
time
um for someone i don't it's almost like
you know we're looking for something
from everyone that we can somehow
dispose them in some way yeah and
that's why it's so frightening right now
was elvis the great love of your life
yes he was
he obviously he obviously sang about
love so many times
when you're on your own perhaps is there
a one song that elvis sang
which resonates most with you
oh my gosh you know there's so many
songs
um
gosh that's hard to pick that's a that's
a hard question that's the hardest one
you've asked me
um
[Laughter]
gosh what's the one when you hear it
come on the radio and you think and your
heart flips a beat when you hear it
well i think it's being in las vegas
watching him do the shows
and um
i think you know the songs that he's
saying that people were all drawn to
uh and and i think that you know all of
us are attached to a song there's so
many with him um i can't even i can't
even tell you it's now or never probably
it's now or never because i heard him
sing that in
germany actually
and
and that was given to him
through the record label
of the company and uh to watch him
sing the song and try to reach the notes
in perfection is what he was looking for
to perfect those notes because he his
tone his his
his uh pitch was not as high uh
in in that particular song so he would
always
try to reach it and mess up and then hit
his leg and
try it again and again and again so
watching him kind of rehearse and trying
to get it right is is was an experience
you can imagine
perfectionist
do you wish priscilla in a way that you
had
never got divorced from elvis and do you
think that his life would have been
different if you'd stay together
um
gosh
um
to be honest i think we were better
not married
um we had a great relationship
um he would come over to my home at all
hours of the night talk it could be two
o'clock three o'clock um i would have my
daughter i'll wake my daughter up be
with us at some of that my mother the
same thing although lisa had to go to
school
uh he would come alone sometimes and
sometimes bring charlie hodge one of his
guys that worked for him or someone else
and we would just sit and talk and he'd
bring him books and he'd read books to
me
and he left me with quite a few books as
well
but
we see everything just seemed to be more
relaxed more at home when the tension
wasn't there now remember i'm with elvis
presley
and um
watching the girls
running up to him wanting kisses from
him
running to the stage
coming backstage
uh
it's a you know it's
listen being who he was
and having all the women you know
jump him
excuse me
um i'm kidding i'm really kidding
i think you're already half kid against
experience
literally just about um anyway
no it was it was
it was
an eye opener for me and um i'm
being married to probably one of the
most famous musicians or singers in the
world
i love everything there isn't anyone
that doesn't love elvis right and i love
how affectionately you talk about it you
know not many divorced spouses would
talk with the kind of love
and admiration that you have for him so
many years of course after he sadly died
he was a great human being he really was
and he tried so hard
you know at what he did to be perfect
and in many many ways you know he wanted
a movie career a good movie career that
was one of the problems as we know you
saw the film that elvis had him tight i
mean that colonel had him tied up with a
five-year contract with hal wallace of
all people
you know hal wallace
did more cutesy movies girls on the
beach as we know
um never really gave him the part that
he longed for
the james dean part
uh that's really what he longed for and
you know what priscilla he had he had
one of the greatest careers that the
world has ever seen in entertainment and
he was a true icon and the movie is
utterly fantastic i'm so glad you loved
it as much as i did we said i've got to
leave it there but i could talk to you
all night thank you so much for your
time i really appreciate it
thank you thank you so much
you